so sei es kinder herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen videospiel heute jump liegt
und ich habe auf twitter gefragt welche
challenge sie denn gerne mal sehen will
in einem video und ganz ganz oft wurde
die ein glas wasser pro kind stand
deswegen hab ich den großen kübel und
hier in glas das nicht zu groß um 0,3
liter und ich werde jetzt für jedes
modul das ich finisher ein glas trinken
je nachdem wie ich mich danach fühle
auch für jeden kill im deathmatch und
wir legen los das glas ist deswegen
nicht so groß weil es durchaus
gefährlich sein kann zu große mengen an
wasser zu sich zu nehmen
das nennt man über besserung oder hydra
zur bewässerung oder überhöhte rotation
ist nicht ungefährlich deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier ein etwas kleineres glas
genommen um mein leben nicht nicht
direkt für die minecraft fans zu
gefährlich weiß nicht manche von euch
die entscheidung nachvollziehen können
aber wir schenken uns hier ein glas
nummer eins und das wird auch so gysi
das wird auch so nicht wirklich was es
auch ziemlich kalt ok ich muss gleich
erstmal bis viel kochsalz oder so
fressen ausgleichen zu können so alles
klar
ein gold wert und der nächste check
point ist hier mit dem nächsten
checkpoint auch schon das nächste glas
war das ist am anfang als richtig
hermine weil chapman so pam pam pam pam
pam kommen hier sind es da und
dann so zeiten wo heute da vorne strecke
nächste held ist es das ist der absolute
killer wasser challenge diese module am
anfang mal wirklich so zack zack zack
zack zack eigentümer first try
durchbrechen
das war ihr habt das was natürlich
runtergeschluckt da muss ich schon das
nächste glas trinken alter schwede
ok-chef seien jetzt gewesen doch
bisschen größer dass es mehr als 0,2
glaube ich okay für mich immer noch gut
alles klar soweit das große problem wird
sein gleich aufzustehen ja einfach
aufzustehen leute einfach aufzustehen
wenn ich davor zwei drei liter wasser so
mehr da wächst habt könnt ihr das wenn
ihr so eine wärmeflasche er hatte früher
als kind auch mehrere flaschen oder wenn
es eine wärmflasche schön mit wasser
voll gemacht hat und die dann so richtig
ein bisschen schüttelte märkte werden
das was ihnen her schlägt ja also würde
ich jetzt mit meinem bauch sein glas
nummer vier
eine davon ist schon ziemlich weiter da
wir schon beim thema sind leute paar
worte kann man für diese begeisterung
erzählen
es kann also man sollte man nie
unterschätzen also ich glaube ich dass
es gefährlich ist man als gesunder
mensch ist die mengen denke ich jetzt
hier trinke aber wenn man zum beispiel
jetzt viel sport draußen gemacht hat
viele elektrolyte verliert und dann viel
electro lied arma2 flüssigkeit zu sich
nimmt dann kann das durchaus gefährlich
sein das heißt trinkt nicht zu viel auf
einen schlag lieber über den tag
verteilt so drei bis vier liter zusammen
zweifel zwei halbtags oder das glaube
ich gar nicht schlecht macht nicht so
ein scheiß wie ich in minecraft alter
dia und eisen in einer kiste 101 geriet
ein fucking krabbes alter was das
verwesen
aber was soll wir machen sondern für
jeden kill ein glas wasser trinken dann
über liebe dieses statement aber nicht
leute also keine 5 ps sind schon normal
wo gott da kommt der erste noch was
machen die sagt wir für jeden zweiten
catering ein ok ja alles lag auf der
nächste junge alles klar okay wir können
uns theoretischen fms pasta nicht etwas
macht manchmal wurden jetzt von denen
ein bisschen weg erwartete
europaparlament
trotzdem so also blüten naja jetzt der
studie da nicht wollen nadal hat die
acht ruderer kommt von irgendwo noch ein
pfeil und trifft mich alles klappt und
eisenschrott oh là là
da mag ich überhaupt mal die biege
folgten thema erstmal nicht es gibt
regen und dann überlegen wir diesen
krabbes angreifen wollen der nämlich
fakten gute rüstung vielleicht fangen
erst mal ein anderes paar andere holen
zum beispiel den hier
zack
ohne leiden
der service ein bisschen länger heute
habe ich das gefühl kann es seien ja
wohl den hammer sehr gut und sie jetzt
bekommen was hat er für uns ein
spannendes oder einen helm brauchen und
sonst äpfel sonst hab ich nicht so viel
da dieser grafik keeper das volle drei
leben
bis jetzt hätten alle leute vielleicht
können wir jetzt mal ein bisschen job
machen
das ist gerade ziemlich viele die jetzt
theoretische angreifen können alles da
ist ja wohl perfekt perfekt dem op typen
und wurde jetzt ein leben abgezogen und
ich habe hier noch in kiel bekommt man
das ist sehr gut und das ist glaube ich
mein zweiter kehle alles klar zweite
heißt es gibt wieder ein glas und zwar
sobald er von der kommt rüber der kommt
rüber
er kommt rüber lauf lauf lauf laufen ja
als ob sie konnte nicht mehr weglaufen
alter moment bitte moment wird ich muss
kurz austrinken jetzt schwitzt doch
nicht so durch die gegend alter.de geil
auf dem kiel kann man sein
wir sind die letzten die in diesem
thread junge da musst du nicht so
unglaublich
brennt da brennt da brennt brennt dann
kommt wenn glos der bild dass es so
richtig wir müssen wissen glas weg
ja wir kommen wäre glaube ich jetzt
geschafft
diese menschen
die drei minuten lang hinterherlaufen
decken versorgt
ja ja noch okay meine kg darf sich nicht
verschlechtert spaß darauf ein glas
wasser das letzte glas wasser im rahmen
der heutigen challenge.de halbwegs
überstanden aber wir können ja nicht
wiederholen also zweiter versuch würde
bedeuten dass ja noch mal zehn gläser
trinken oder so deswegen belassen wir's
mal dabei und ich danke fürs zuschauen
danke für die ganze unterstützung der
letzten tagen das war es von mir von
heute morgen gibt es ja schon bis dahin
haut rein macht's gut und ja